und es gibt neuen zoff um layla in den
charts weiter ganz oben die deutschen
lieben diesen song die spd aber die
saison geht zumindest offiziell sich
dann in der partei gibt es jetzt riesen
aufregung um laila weil eine kleine
gruppe von sbb land das gemacht hat was
millionen deutsche sie vermutlich auch
zu hause tun sie haben leider gesungen
leider die wohl bekannteste buch mama
deutschland sorgt in diesem sommer für
viel gute laune und reichlich
diskussionen
[Musik]
nachdem der originaltext vom zdf
zunächst abgelehnt wurde feierte die
großmama nun auch dort premiere die
zuschauer des zdf fernsehgartens
feierten den partyhit ausgiebig so sehr
dass sie sogar zugabe gab
st
macke marc
der sky moderatorin andrea kiewel vieles
doch was beim öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk gefällt muss noch lange nicht
für die spd gelten auf dem christopher
street day in stuttgart waren die
sozialdemokraten am wochenende mit einem
wagen dabei die stimmung ausgelassen der
dj treibt die massen an für einige
minuten sorgt er auch prof mama layla
für partystimmung
jetzt hagelt es kritik und zwar aus den
eigenen reihen das lied wurde
abgebrochen doch die parteiinterne
debatte eskaliert
die arbeitsgemeinschaft der spd für
akzeptanz und gleichstellung kündigt auf
twitter konsequenzen an man habe sich
umgehend mit den genossinnen in
stuttgart in verbindung gesetzt wir
distanzieren uns ausdrücklich vom
abspielen dieses songs auf einem csd
wagen und lehnen jede art sexistischer
oder misogynie musik ab für das deutsche
partyvolk mittlerweile langweiliges
gerede ob volksfest oder festival ganz
deutschland feiert in diesem sommer
leider lässt sich das mit grün nicht
verbieten
[Musik]
nur die spd befindet sich noch in der
textanalyse
[Musik]
der textanalyse teilen der spd ist es
also peinlich dass andere teile der spd
leider gesungen haben ein klartext
politiker aus der spd der findet dafür
diese worte heinz buschkowsky nämlich
der langjährige neuköllner bürgermeister
hier von der spd der sagt diese leute
sind gartenzwerge also die verzwergung
die hat schon stattgefunden es geht zu
ende mit dieser spd sagt heinz
buschkowsky wegen dieser laila affäre
wie kaputt ist dieser verquere haufen
wenn er sich über schlagertexter aufregt
stadt über die akuten krisen dieser tage
diese leute sind gartenzwerg also dass
die klartext analyse von heinz
buschkowsky über die parteigenossen
[Musik]